the integrity of our elections is in
peril tonight we may be witnessing yet
another in a series of stolen elections
in Florida Democrats are experts at
pulling Swifties at the ballot box you
know it's widely believed that they
resorted to voter fraud in Illinois and
in Texas to tilt the election of John F
Kennedy over Nixon in 1960 and they may
be up to their old tricks again valid
irregularities in Palm Beach and Broward
counties in Florida are front and center
the president of course has been very
vocal about what he believes is
happening there you take a look at the
past take a look at the past and all of
a sudden they're finding votes you mean
after the election they're finding votes
predictably the media have rushed in to
pooh-pooh any notion of voter fraud
there is no evidence to back up the
claim aimed at the Florida recount but
it offers a window into the president's
state of mind to be very clear and I
just want to make sure everybody at home
understands there's no evidence of that
story it's a it's a fever dream it's
like it never happened
the New York Times yesterday wrote in
Florida no one has offered evidence of
widespread election fraud no one
I love the weasel word widespread Nieto
if one or two counties in Florida are
engaged in voter fraud it is widespread
it affects the entire state results and
the results perhaps with the rest of the
country let's examine the facts things
are so bad in Palm Beach that Governor
Rick Scott who's in a tight Senate race
there sued the county election
supervisor Susan Bucher the judge
determined that she had illegally
withheld over voted in under voted
ballots from the canvassing board and
worse she's refused to allow public
scrutiny of the ballots
Scott is vowed to fight back against
Democrats playing fast and loose with
the voters will I will not sit idly by
while unethical liberals try to steal
this election than the great people of
Florida and the governor is also sued
Broward County elections supervisor
something of a kind of her own rock star
these days Brenda Snipes now Snipes is
well a piece of work her predecessor
remember was
really walked out of her office in 2003
for grave neglect
mismanagement and incompetence
practically a tradition down there in
Broward and in May a judge found Brenda
Snipes guilty of illegally destroying
ballots during a primary election in
2016 then in August a court found her
guilty of secretly opening mail in
ballots which is illegal in the state
then on Friday
Governor Scott won his lawsuit against
Snipes the court found that in this
election she continued to discover new
ballots she was found in violation of
the state's public records laws and has
been ordered to release information to
Governor Scott so far she hasn't
complied with the order you refused to
give the Scott campaign the information
they wanted it had to go to court the
judge said you had to turn it over you
didn't turn it over by the deadline that
was given that is cast as a partisan
spat but you're doing that because
you're a Democrat how do you respond to
that well I was talking with a woman
today as she came into our office and
she made some statement about a partisan
statement and she said I know that
you're Republican I said I have been a
Democrat all my life in this position I
have been very focused on party because
I want to treat all of the voters in
Broward County the same we don't select
who we give out information to we give
information to those persons who have
requested it and I believe the public
records request isn't in a timely manner
and we attempt to do that did she
actually hear the question this woman is
unbelievable the Miami Herald reports an
election worker found bags of uncounted
early ballots in the Broward County
Elections office Snipes also mingled
rejected provisional ballots with the
accepted ones and then she proceeded to
count them all on the official vote
tally Nieto now a recount is underway
where the counters must discern the
intent of the voters if there is a mark
on the ballot here or there my friends
is a complete travesty that cannot be
permitted to change the outcome
of this election and it's sadly not
restricted to the Sunshine State we're
gonna show you what some Democrats are
trying in Georgia in just moments so
what's next I think it's the Cavanaugh I
demonstrated Republicans must stand
united to expose the malfeasance and the
fraud of the left because when we do we
usually win you can't allow this
flouting of the rules and procedures by
corrupt officials or political hacks
can't let it stand and if we allow this
to go unchecked it will undermine our
democracy and like a contagion it's
gonna spread across the nation 18 years
can you believe it since Bush v Gore
it's absolutely unforgivable that we're
still dealing with these types of issues
it is time for the Department of Justice
to step in and do a top-to-bottom
investigation regarding why these issues
still persist and if necessary people
are gonna have to go to jail there have
to be repercussions for willful
fraudulent defiance of electoral laws if
this isn't cleaned up I'm telling you
the GOP can kiss any hopes of restoring
the majority let alone a presidential
victory they can kiss it bye-bye in 2020
and that's the angle